aisha liga sieben haben eine bewegte
biografie ihre eltern kamen als
iranische juden nach deutschland später
sind sie nach israel gegangen und waren
sogar einer der sprecher der
israelischen armee ab heute betrachtet
was glauben sie wielange würde iran
brauchen um einen atomaren sprengkopf zu
produzieren also wir leben in einer
realität wo man eigentlich gar nichts
mehr wirklich einschätzen kann
das heißt selbst die hellsten köpfe
können nicht wirklich sagen genau
deadlines geben
es ist jetzt vor kurzem in israel kam
aus den sicherheitsdiensten kam eine
analyse raus die gesagt hat wenn es so
weitergeht und die iraner wirklich jetzt
anfangen hardcore zu produzieren ende
2020 dass es pessimistisch gesehen
könnten sie schon atomar bewaffnet seien
optimistisch 20 22 das heißt wir sind
jetzt gerade in einer periode wo man
wirklich schön gas geben muss um
wir haben hier ähnliche ziele nämlich an
dass der iran nicht atomar wird was
würde es für israel bedeuten wenn der
iran die atombombe hätte also die frage
ist nicht nur was es für israel bedeutet
sondern ich zitiere kurz den
generalsekretär der arabischen liga
berät hat vor kurzem erst gesagt man
muss sich nicht wundern wenn die iraner
und vielleicht auch die türken nuclear
eines tages bewaffnet sind werden alle
araber mitziehen
das heißt hier geht es wirklich um einen
wettlauf ein atomaren wettlauf der nicht
nur zwischen israel und dem iran sondern
die ganze region schaut so sind sehr
viele die auf der schau zusammenschluss
zuschauer tribüne sitzen und das ist
höchst gefälscht dass wir muss man
unbedingt jetzt gleich in den den iran
aufhalten
heiko maas bundesaußenminister was würde
eine iranische bombe für europa bedeuten
sie würde glaube ich die sicherheitslage
nicht nur im mittleren osten
auf den kopf stellen sondern sie würde
auch die sicherheitslage bis nach europa
ganz dramatisch verändern
und deshalb müssen wir bei alldem was
wollen ja alle dass der iran keine
kernwaffen besitzt
wenn es dieses abkommen nicht gegeben
hätte dann müsste man befürchten dass
der iran schon jetzt im besitz einer
atomwaffe wäre und deshalb halten wir
daran fest wir brauchen dieses abkommen
wir sind nicht damit einverstanden dass
der iran seine verpflichtungen aus setzt
deshalb haben wir auch diesen
sogenannten streitschlichtung
mechanismus zusammen mit
was würde es bedeuten wenn sie sie
hätten für europa in bezug auf
flüchtlings krisen in bezug auf ölkrisen
in bezug auf malt man sich das aus
eigentlich will man es nicht sich
ausmalen sondern wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass das gar nicht erst so weit kommt
aber sicherlich würde das auswirkungen
haben die die sicherheitslage die
geostrategische lage im nahen und
mittleren osten komplett verändern würde
und deshalb muss ist dabei bleiben dass
der iran keine kernwaffen hat und wir
müssen als europäer aber auch zusammen
mit den vereinigten staaten wege finden
wie das auch in zufällig zu gewähren
constanze stelzenmüller ist bei uns
politikwissenschaftlerin arbeitet für
den us think tank brookings das atom
abkommen auf dass die europäer ja sehr
stolz sind und immer waren hat den iran
gebremst aber nicht gestoppt
denken sie dass er überhaupt die
atomaren träume aufgegeben hat also
sagen wir so ich bin mit meinem nachbarn
zur echten einverstanden dass man glaube
ich großes misstrauen haben muss
gegenüber offiziellen verlautbarung aus
teheran
die iraner spielen seit vielen vielen
jahren mit multiplen erzählebenen und
multiplen wahrheiten und sie haben aber
auch noch zwei wirklich gute gründe eine
atomwaffe zu verfolgen und die heiße
mode muammar gaddafi und kim jong-un sie
haben gesehen dass das fehlen von
atomwaffen dazu führen kann dass jemand
wie muammar gaddafi im gefolge einer
westlichen intervention 2012 von seinen
eigenen landsleuten umgebracht wurde und
kim jong un wird von donald trump
äußerst respektvoll behandelt weil so
die landläufige ansicht weil er an einem
atomwaffenprogramm hat und davon
gelassen wird und ich glaube das ist ein
sehr starkes motiv veteran weiter in
diesem programm festzuhalten und wie man
sie davon sind sollen lust ist wirklich
schwierige frage dann müsste man diesen
anderen aspekte auch mit bedenken mit
bedenken bei uns ist das osterei sie
sind 2004 frau esther aus dem iran
geflohen hat donald trump die mullahs in
teheran tatsächlich durchschaut und die
europäer waren zu naiv und so gutgläubig
in ihren verhandlungen mit ihm
ich muss erst mal sagen ich bin nicht
geflohen zum glück ich bin als studentin
nach deutschland gekommen aber ich kann
leider nicht mehr zurück weil ich
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr zurück nach
deutschland kann
aber was die europäer angeht ich glaube
sie sind naiv gewesen weil sie sehr viel
hoffnung in europa nie und seine
regierung gesetzt haben und auch sehr
vieles was ja brief der außenminister
vom iran gesagt hat abgekauft haben
indem er schon aber ich glaube iran
musste ja
das atom deal akzeptieren so zu sagen
weil die sie standen wirklich finanziell
mit dem rücken an gewandt und aber auch
wir sowohl die em israelischer als auch
die amerikanische sicherheits- statement
immer gesagt haben war dieses atom deal
ein erfolg eigentlich den iran daran zu
verhindern an atommacht zu werden und
ich glaube wenn in dieser atom also
jetzt laut der letzten israelischen
bericht vom geheimdienst auch wir haben
nicht mehr viel zeit also wir müssen
wirklich einen neuen gegen mit dem iran
aushandeln
da müssen wir aber auch andere fragen
die frage der ballistischen raketen
kommen die menschenrechtsfrage mit
angenehmen mit ihm aufnehmen und iran
versuchen daran zu verhindern eine art
um das heißt wer hoch im grunde auch ein
plädoyer für einen neuen deal oder
werten einen erweiterten deal bei uns in
florence gaub sie sind stellvertretende
direktorin beim europäischen institut
für sicherheitsstudien und eine militär
soziologin frau gab es ist
hochinteressant die kontrolleure der
atombehörde bescheinigen dem iran
regelmäßig vertragstreue ist unser
misstrauen also unbegründet
schauen sie in internationaler politik
geht eigentlich nicht darum wer jetzt
faktisch recht oder unrecht hat sondern
was die wahrnehmung ist und ich glaube
das ist teil des problems was diesen
deal betrifft diese die ich denke dieses
dieses vor zurück ist der deal jetzt
noch eingehalten war wie es liegt die
beweislage bei wem verkennt die tatsache
dass der deal aus unserer sicht dazu
dient den iran von einer atomaren waffen
abzuhalten aber eigentlich der die logik
die dahinter stand 2003 als es losging
mit den verhandlungen war einen konflikt
zu verhindern
der nämlich jetzt wieder im raum steht
das heißt für uns natürlich dass unsere
perspektive geht es dabei um die bombe
aus iranischer perspektive geht es darum
einen militärischen konflikt zu
verhindern
und ich glaube das problem was wir
damals verkannt haben war ich weiß nicht
ich würde nicht sagen dass das naiv der
richtige ausdruck ist aber dass dazu
mehr gehört als
richtige realistische ziele in dem alles
festgelegtes sondern dass alle parteien
des konflikts diesem gilt auch vertrauen
und wenn ich sage alle parteien denn da
gehört zum beispiel für mich auch dazu
israel aber auch saudi arabien die
regionalen nachbarn die dem iran nicht
vertrauen
ultimativ vertrauen auch die usa dem
iran nicht das heißt der deal an sich
ist nicht das problem sondern die
tatsache dass da nicht genug vertrauen
ist und zum beispiel weder israel noch
iran waren mit am verhandlungstisch
damals war nicht mit einbezogen da gibt
es natürlich deswegen weiterhin nach wie
vor misstrauen dem iran gegenüber gibt
auch gute gründe dem iran sind
misstrauen würde ich auch sagen deswegen
was jetzt nötig ist es nicht ein neuer
ausgehungerter deal mit noch mehr
prozedere noch mehr noch mehr paragrafen
die auch alle richtig sind aber in
erster linie den kontext schaffen in dem
wieder mehr vertrauen mit an den tisch
gebracht wird und ich glaube das füttern
wiederum zu einem ja zu einem deal der
dann uns an das ziel bringt keine
atomwaffe thoma für in teheran und für
die iraner kein militärischer konflikte
und dann trotzdem noch mal natürlich der
verweis auf donald trump der heiko maas
offensichtlich auf abschreckung setzt
nicht nur mit der aufkündigung genau
dieses abkommens sondern auch mit der
tötung von general sulimani betreibt er
ja wenigstens dem prinzip nach
abschreckung die frage waren wir zu
gutgläubig sind wir zu gutgläubig und zu
vertrauensselig den iran gegenüber
ich glaube gar nicht dass wir gut
gläubig sind oder vertrauensselig
sondern wir haben auch viel misstrauen
das ist einer der gründe gewesen warum
es überhaupt dieses abkommen gegeben hat
wir haben nach einem weg gesucht im
übrigen damals ja mit den vereinigten
staaten zusammen die vereinigten staaten
haben damals federführend dieses
abkommen mit ausgehandelt weil wir
gesagt haben wir trauen ihnen nicht und
wir wollen dafür sorgen dass sie sich
uns gegenüber verpflichten keine
atomwaffen zu entwickeln
auf der anderen seite haben wir dafür
sanktionen die es bis dahin gegeben hat
ausgesetzt es ist immer ein geben und
nehmen
aber ich glaube dass der weg der weitaus
effektivere ist als das mit maximaler
drogen und maximaler abschreckung zu tun
denn seitdem die vereinigten staaten aus
dem atom abkommen ausgetreten sind hat
sich
nichts verbessert also wir sind keinen
schritt weitergekommen und deshalb sagen
wir lassen uns doch dieses abkommen
erhalten und die fragen über die wir
auch reden wollen wie geht es danach
weiter dieses abkommen ist zeitlich
befristet
wir sind nicht einverstanden mit der
rolle die der iran in der region spielt
in syrien im jemen im libanon auch
gegenüber israel
das sind fragen die auf den tisch kommen
dass man auch mit den ballistischen
raketen programm das auch eine bedrohung
für israel ist darüber reden will
braucht man einen gesprächspartner also
wir brauchen auch gründe und angebote
den iran an den tisch zu bekommen wir so
lässt sich überhaupt vertrauen schaffen
und ich habe nicht den eindruck aus den
letzten monaten dass das was mit
maximalem druck aus washington
es versucht wird uns irgend einem
schritt weitergebracht hat okay frau
stelzenmüller wir müssen noch mal
verstehen wie ist die sicht in
washington darauf donald trump sagt
dieses abkommen ist ein schlechter deal
weil es von barack obama unterzeichnet
wurde oder ist es wirklich ein
schlechtes abkommen also in washington
gibt es unterschiedliche sichtweisen
weil es in dieser regierung
unterschiedliche elemente gibt aber in
einem sind sich der präsident und die
wichtigsten seine wichtigsten mitspieler
insbesondere sein außenminister hob er
auch jetzt am wochenende zu einer
libyen-konferenz kommt und ich glaube
sein verteidigungsminister erste einig
und das ist eine diese strategie des
maximalen drucks und maximale härte es
kursieren über die motive dieses
anschlags diese tötung von von von
sulimani dem kommandeur der kuds
brigaden verschiedene theorien das
pentagon habe ihm eine powerpoint
gezeigt wo das als maximale als extreme
option da war um die anderen plausibler
und besser aussehen zu lassen
und trump habe sich dann für die
entschieden es gibt auch die these dass
trump seit 1979 mit der geiselnahme von
von amerikanischen bürgern sozusagen
obsessiv sich beschäftigt hat ich glaube
die richtige analyse ist die dass das
die die hauptakteurin beschränken sich
alle einig sind dass die strategie des
engagement von obama und seinen
vorgängern gescheitert ist weil sie an
den eigentlichen sozusagen der
zielgeraden iranischen halten nichts
geändert hat und dass man das nur ändern
kann wenn man drauf haut so ich glaube
persönlich und das sagen auch viele
stimmen in washington auch stimmen im
establishment erster das war
völkerrechtlich nicht egal
zweitens das ist technisch hoch
problematisch das ist nicht eingebettet
in eine größere überlegung und deshalb
sind jetzt washington und teheran in
eine eskalation logik sozusagen ein
gekettet die aber glaube ich für die
europäer
sowohl risiko ist auch eine chance für
für angebote zur deeskalation für
angebote weil es eine solche eskalation
gibt dass man sich jetzt verständigen
amerika schädlich ist und für
amerikanische interessen in der region
ok frau österreicher jetzt sagt
präsident johann i er wollte sind die
amerikaner und will die amerikaner aus
dem nahen osten haben hatten ebay also
hat ihn in gewisser weise donald trump
dabei sogar geholfen mit der ermordung
von sulimani gibt es jetzt einen noch
besseren grund zu sagen die amerikaner
müssen raus hier aus der region
es gab tatsächlich eine sehr anti
amerikanische stimmung amerikanische
stimmung nach der tötung von sulimani
also auch viele gemäßigte stimme gepaart
mit nationalismus also eine angst vor
dem krieg und gepaart mit nationalismus
hat viele gemäßigt der iraner dazu
gebracht sich hinter der regierung zu
stellen und zu sagen wir wollen keine
sozusagen eigentlichen ausländischer
kräfte und es gab so eine sehr schlimme
stimmung im land wo ich gedacht habe
dass ich meine freunde verliere aber
[Musik]
jetzt hat die stimmung mit den letzten
protesten nach dem absturz von
[Musik]
die krähen international sie ist
bedingung ein bisschen wieder gedreht
dazu reden wir auch noch herrscht alica
die frage wie sehr fühlt sich jetzt
eigentlich israel von donald trump
unterstützt und gäbe es eine alternative
aus ihrer sicht zu diesem abkommen also
wenn man das abkommen nicht will und da
ist donald trump nicht allein sondern
auch benjamin netanjahu sagt das ist ein
fehler und auch boris johnson sagt
mittlerweile es ist ein schlechtes
abkommen hat man denn eine alternative
also wenn es militärische möglichkeiten
gäbe dieses atomprogramm zu zerstören
hätte man die wahrscheinlich längst
gezogen
es gibt eine alternative militärische
mitstreiter müssen ganz am ende stehen
dass man dialog muss vollkommen
ausgeschöpft sein
es ist klar mittlerweile dass der
amerikaner und die israelis glauben an
maximum pressure die europäer glauben
wahrscheinlich druck ganz genau die
europäer ein bisschen weniger aber was
feststeht ist dass die europäer wieder
amerikaner die israel ist und auch die
golfstaaten alle ein bis strategisch ist
dasselbe ziel haben
man ist sich in der taktik nicht einig
das heißt deutschland frankreich england
hat bis vor kurzem ich weiß nicht ob das
immer noch der fall ist daran geglaubt
das pressure druck nicht gut dialog und
wir bleiben im gespräch punkt aus israel
washington hört man oft druck druck
druck weniger gespräch ich glaube man
müsste vielleicht ein dass meine
persönliche meinung einen mittelweg
finden wo man druck verbindet mit
gespräch hört an sich ein bisschen nach
einer illusion an
aber ich meine dass es teil der
diplomatie um irgendwie auch mit
konfliktparteien doch irgendwie was das
gespräch
wenigstens einer ist aus dieser
europäischen
die ja schon ausgebrochen ansonsten
nämlich denen sie vorgestern noch
getroffen haben und von diesem abkommen
überzeugen wollten aus amerikanischer
sicht das jetzige abkommen fehlerhaft es
läuft aus plus es wurde von präsident
obama ausgehandelt wenn wir es also
aufgeben dann lasst es uns präsident
trump ist ein großartiger deal maker
nach eigenen angaben und viele andere
lasst uns zusammen arbeiten um das atom
abkommen mit iran durch den tram tier zu
ersetzen die ju instinkt so da ist der
fürsprecher für den tramp dilemmas
wollen sie ihn auch noch überzeugen oder
sagen sie wir müssen jetzt tatsächlich
akzeptieren dass wir politik nicht ohne
die usa und schon gar nicht gegen die
usa machen kann ich glaube dass man ihn
gar nicht überzeugen muss am letzten
sonntag haben boris johnson immer nur
makro und angela merkel eine gemeinsame
erklärung abgegeben wenn der steht drin
dass wir den atom deal erhalten wohl
weil wir finden das ist die richtige
grundlage um über alle anderen themen zu
sprechen und wir gehen jetzt genau
diesen mittelweg wir erhöhen auch den
druck
deshalb haben wir diesen
streitschlichtung mechanismus eben atom
abkommen ausgelöst das heißt jetzt haben
wir eine frist von 2 x 15 tagen die kann
verlängert werden in diesen 15 2 x 15
tagen muss mit dem iran verhandelt
werden und der irak wo es zur einhaltung
seiner verpflichtung wieder bewogen wird
wenn das alles nicht funktionieren würde
würde der atomdeal irgendwann im
sicherheitsrat der vereinten nationen
landen und alle sanktionen gegen den
iran würden wieder aufgerufen das wollen
wir nicht
wir wollen dass der iran seine
verpflichtungen einhält und insofern ist
der weg der europa genau der den sie
beschrieben haben
wir sind nicht einverstanden dass der
iran jetzt fünf phasen erklärt in denen
er immer wieder sagt wir setzen das aus
und dann setzen wir das aus sondern wir
wollen jetzt ergebnisse und wir wollen
den iran dazu anhalten diese
verpflichtungen wieder einzuhalten
das heißt der druck wird jetzt erhöht es
geht nicht ganz ohne druck aber der
druck darf nie dazu führen dass die
gespräche abbrechen und
doch die militär logik das ganze
bestimmt denn dafür ist der gesamte nahe
und mittlere osten mittlerweile viel zu
sehr ein einziges pulverfass geworden
und das muss man glaube ich wenn man auf
den iran klickt mit im auge haben dass
es um eine ganze region geht die man
leicht in flammen setzen und trotzdem
noch einmal das argument von constanze
stelzenmüller die tötung von sulimani
hat donald trump damit auch in ihren
augen herr maas eine politisch rote
linie überschritten hat er völkerrecht
gebrochen
also wenn wir uns jetzt die diskussion
vor allen dingen in bagdad anschauen
bagdad hat das dortige parlament eine
resolution verfasst der steht tritt alle
ausländischen streitkräfte sollen das
land verlassen es ist die anti gs
koalition unterstützen den irak im kampf
gegen den esd hat zwar kein eigenes
territorium er aber den gibt's noch im
untergrund der verübt mittlerweile
anschläge
und wenn das das ergebnis der sohle
money tötung ist das im irak weil man
das als eine souveränitäts verletzung
begreift diejenigen aus dem landkreis
die eingestellt sind um den irak mit
wieder aufzubauen dann servieren wir im
ergebnis den irak dem iran auf dem
silbertablett und das kann wirklich
nicht im interesse der vereinigten
staaten sein das ist auf jeden fall
nicht in unserem interesse und das
vertreten wer zurzeit mit der irakischen
regierung um die voraussetzungen dafür
zu schaffen dass der kampf gegen den ds
weitergeht und dem iran nicht allzu
einfach das dass der boden bereitet wird
all das was man gemeinsam sondern ist im
irak wieder einzureißen innerhalb
kürzester zeit noch mal die frage hat
donald trump völkerrecht gebrochen war
das eine völkerrechtswidrige attacke auf
sony und auch auf einen irakischen
general im entwicklung einige staaten
berufen sich auf artikel 51 der
un-charta das selbstverteidigungsrecht
ist es unzweifelhaft im vorfeld gab es
anschläge auf amerikanische
einrichtungen ist kein protest
organisiert waren gegen die
amerikanische botschaft
und die vereinigten staaten sagen dass
es konkrete hinweise auf bevorstehende
anschläge und angriffe gegeben hat und
aus diesem grund ist so le manie getötet
worden sie nehmen dieses
selbstverteidigungsrecht dafür in
anspruch
wir kennen keine konkreten hinweise die
müssten wir kennen um das beurteilen zu
können sondern scheint gibt es in der
amerikanischen regierung ja selber
diskussionen darüber wie konkret diese
hinweise gegeben sind also das muss man
erst mal in washington klären bevor man
uns die frage gestellt ob das
ausreichende indizien hinweise sind die
auf bevorstehende angriffe oder also
eine mittelbare bedrohungen und das hat
selbst verteidigungsminister es bei
ausgeschlossen er hat diese belege nicht
das wird in washington immer noch
diskutiert was glauben sie wie groß ist
die gefahr dass wir es als ein
mittlerweile normales mittel von politik
ansehen so menschen auszuschalten
ich glaube das ist das risiko dass immer
bei solchen aktionen entsteht weshalb es
so wichtig ist die sorgfältig zu
begründen und auch im rahmen des
möglichen man muss dabei natürlich auch
sagen solche solche entscheidungen
werden getroffen auf der grund von
geheimdienstlichen erkenntnisse die man
nicht sozusagen den medien oder dem
frühstücksfernsehen servieren kann
das heißt das ist schwer so etwas
öffentlich zu begründen
aber man sollte das sehr sparsam und
sehr sorgfältig behandeln weil immer das
risiko entsteht dass der grundsatz der
reziprozität also dagegen der
gegenseitigen inanspruchnahme des
schutzes erfolgreichste im in dem im
militär völkerrecht besonders wichtig
ist dass der erodiert und ich wurde
nochmals auf den punkt von israel sagen
wenn ich darf benjamin netanyahu oder
sonst keine gelegenheit auslässt kann
kein licht zwischen trump und sich zu
lassen
selbst benjamin netanyahu der
premierminister von israel hat gesagt
dies ist eine angelegenheit der
amerikaner
da waren wir nicht beteiligt also daraus
das spricht bände
in diesem zusammenhang dass er da sehr
zurückhaltend und sehr leise war israels
hat man auch schon mal die chance tolle
manny und seine verbündeten sozusagen
auszuschalten wie man so sagt es
natürlich ein euphemismus zu töten und
haben davon abgesehen weil sie sozusagen
sehr sorgfältig abgewägt haben das was
die konsequenzen und die risiken
unterliegt und wir erinnern uns noch mal
frau glaubt dass wir angela merkel
zitiert haben mit ihrem satz in der
knesset das ist deutscher staatsraison
misst den schutz israel zu organisieren
was würde das bedeuten am ende dieses
bekenntnis auch für deutschland bedeuten
dass wir israel schützen wollen was ich
vorhin schon gesagt haben was mich
grundsätzlich an der diskussion zum iran
die ein bisschen stört ist dass man eben
das gefühl bekommt es geht hier nur um
ein geopolitisches internationales
problem war es um nukleare proliferation
sich im endeffekt handeln tut es aber
nicht
im kern geht es darum wie der iran sich
in die internationale völkerfamilie
integriert und als ihre regionale macht
im nahen osten gibt es eben ein großes
unaufgelöste problem
das heißt wir können nicht nur diese
diskussion haben über den nuklearen deal
wir müssen auch die regionale diskussion
haben die gehören zusammen und ich würde
sogar sagen auch den nationale
diskussion wie wir uns positionieren
gegenüber den protesten im iran auf
regeln haller ebene und sie sprach ist
gerade israel an das ist dass es der
schwelende konflikt im nahen und
mittleren osten
es ist natürlich auf nationaler ebene
saudi arabien iran wenn es auf cholera
ebene sag ich mal schiiten und sunniten
es spielt im libanon die hisbollah die
juzis sind auf jeden fall ideologisch
zumindest mit dem iran verbandelt dann
wissen wir dass der iran in syrien für
eine rolle spielt dass man die liste
geht wenig sagen die iren hatten die
zeit gut genutzt die ganz oben ihren
machtbereich auszuweiten ja aber gut
dass man wenn sie wollen können jetzt
tief in die indy
syrien frage einsteigen die leute gerne
bei und unsere verpflichtung ganz genau
aber dass wir haben genau deswegen wegen
israel aber auch wegen den all den
anderen muss die diskussion weitergehen
als bombe oder nicht sie muss in denen
die jetzt muss gehen in was welche rolle
spielt der iran in der region und
einfach nur sagen ihr macht lauter böse
sachen das ist entscheidend nicht die
antwort so wir haben jetzt schon über
über es bekommen richtig cool
weltraummedizin gesprochen und jetzt
fragen wir auch noch mal nach der
israelischen position mechaniker was
würden sie sich von den europäern den
wünschen was würde ich mir wünschen er
es erstmal sehr viele wünsche die sharp
es muss jetzt auspacken aber generell
bin ich persönlich auf vielen ebenen
unterwegs und ich bin ja auch perser ich
habe familie im iran
ich hab selber noch familie im iran und
ich habe manchmal das gefühl dass ich
meinen reuters hat ja auch berichtet
dass jetzt november/dezember internet
wurde ausgeschaltet
1500 menschen wurden ermordet tausende
von menschen wurden abgeführt wir wissen
alle was im evin-gefängnis was so
passiert manche leute werden sie wieder
das licht der welt erblicken
ich habe manchmal gefühl dass wir das
alles irgendwie so ein bisschen nicht
ganz wahr nehmen wollen sondern so ein
bisschen abtun
dieses im gespräch bleiben mit müllers
mit einem islamistischen regime was
menschen ab führt was menschen
öffentlich tötet frauen misshandelt
vergewaltigt oppositionelle journalisten
minderheiten bei heiß das ist eine sache
die mir persönlich sehr weh tut dieser
familie der stadt hat dort familie
es tut mir weh als perser als regel
natürlich kommt noch hinzu das ist die
direkte sag ich jetzt mal gefahr dort
fühle raketen rees boller syrien gaza
nehmen sogar irak das heißt ein mehr
fronten raketen sag ich jetzt mal eine
bedrohung aus verschiedenen ebenen und
als deutscher im endeffekt bin ich hier
geboren ich bin hier groß geworden das
ist die sprache die gespräche habe ich
manchmal gefühl dass man als deutscher
da auch irgendwie aus der geschichte
habe ich vermutet gelernt hat aus der
eigenen geschichte
das
unschuldige menschen ermorden
beziehungsweise zu schauen wir
unschuldige menschen ermordet werden das
machen wir deutschen nicht mit punkt da
müssen wir aktiv sein das können wir mit
unserem eigenen gewissen nicht ausmachen
und natürlich muss man zuerst den dialog
und noch einmal den dialog und mit
freunden und mit partnern und bündnisse
und der wunsch ist und das ist das
problem das er eigentlich sprechen dass
der amerikaner und die europäer die
letzten jahre leider nicht eine sprache
sprechen
man muss den besten einigen um dort
wirklich im nahen osten und dem
mittleren osten den haupt störenfried zu
bändigen
das ist nun mal das islamistische regime
in teheran